en el último vídeo nos preguntábamos
acerca de la suma de todos los factores
de 27.000 y bueno lo que quiero hacer en
este vídeo es retomar este asunto
analizarlo con más calma y ver cómo
llegamos al resultado ahora bien lo que
sí quiero que te acuerdes es que en el
vídeo pasado tomamos el 27.000 y lo
descompusimos en números primos y los
números primos que no salieron fue 3 a
la 3 2 a la 3 y 5 a la 3 3 al cubo por 2
al jugo por 5 al cubo esto es lo mismo
que 27.000 y bueno esto era bastante
importante porque justo esto nos está
diciendo que todos los divisores de
27.000 tienen como factores potencias
del 3 del 2 y del 5 es decir todos los
factores de 27.000 los podemos ver de la
siguiente forma como 3 a la equis por 2
al aiem por 5 a la zeta
donde vamos a decir que las potencias x
y z son potencias que son enteras y
además existen entre 0 y 3 es decir
pueden ser 0 1 2 ó 3 cualquier
combinación de estas potencias
nos tomemos al aplicarlas a esta función
de factores nos van a dar factores de
27.000 y no hay más todos los factores
de 27.000 se tienen que ver de esta
manera por ejemplo si no me quiero tomar
el 7 el 7 no es factor de 20.000 porque
no se puede escribir de esta manera y si
yo me tomo por ejemplo el 3 hará cero
por 2 al cuadrado por 5 1 esto como 7 la
forma de los factores de 27.000 entonces
va a dividir a 27.000 esto cuánto me dan
3 el acero es 12 al cuadrados 45 a la 1
es 5 y 4 por 5 es 20 entonces 20 va a
dividir a 27.000 y la división es exacta
entonces todos los factores de 27.000
son de esta forma 13 la equis por 2 al
ayer por 5 a la zeta ahora bien lo que
hicimos también en el vídeo pasado fue
intentar hacer una tabla y en esta tabla
empezamos a aplicar no solamente en las
potencias del 3 y del 2 es decir 30 31
32 33 20 21 22 y 23
es decir en 13 927 y 1
4 4 2 y 8 estas son las potencias que
nos tomamos y suponemos que la potencia
que nos íbamos a tomar del 5 era 50 y es
que entonces con todas estas potencias y
vamos a crear una tabla de todas las
posibles combinaciones de la
multiplicación de estos date cuenta que
cualquier combinación de la
multiplicación de estos es un divisor de
27.000 y pues bueno si empezamos esta
tabla que nos quedan 1 por 111 por 3 3 1
por 1 de 9 1 por mil 727 todos estos son
factores de 27.000 y si ahora yo
multiplico el 2 por cada uno de estos 2
por 1 2 2 por 3 6 2 por 9 18 y 297 54
también todos estos son factores de
27.000 y de igual manera si yo hiciera
lo mismo con el 4 y con el 8 sin embargo
a dijimos que no había necesidad de
hacer esto porque recuerda que nosotros
nos queremos fijar en la suma de todos
estos factores no en quiénes son todos
estos factores y bueno si no sumamos la
suma del primer renglón esto no queda 13
927 lo cual nos evitó ha pasado que era
40 sin embargo aquí es donde empieza lo
distinto el vídeo pasado quiero que te
des cuenta que esto es lo mismo
nuestra primera potencia del 2 que
multiplica a todos estos ahora bien si
quisiéramos tomar la suma de la segunda
columna tendríamos la segunda potencia
del 2 que es 2 a la 1 es decir 2 que
multiplica a 13 927 ojo date cuenta que
la segunda columna la obtuvimos
multiplicando la primera columna por 2 2
por 1 2 2 por 3 6 2 por 9 18 2 por 27 54
por lo tanto la tercera columna saldría
de multiplicar el 4 por la primera
columna y cuando me tomo la suma me
quedaría 4 que multiplica a 13 más 9 27
sacándolo como factor común y de igual
manera para la última columna sería 8
que multiplica a 13 + 9 más 27 sacándolo
como factor común y esto es porque si
nosotros quisiéramos sacar la cuarta
columna habría que multiplicar a 8 por
la primera columna y bueno date cuenta
que esta es la suma de todos los
factores de 27.000 que tienen que ver
con 5 elevado a la potencia cero porque
aquí no pusimos ninguna multiplicación
por 5 elevado a ninguna potencia es
decir no estamos tomando 5 elevado a la
potencia 0 pero
aquí hay algo padrísimo porque 13 + 9
más 27 es un factor común por lo tanto
lo puedo sacar y me queda 139 más 27 que
multiplica a su vez a uno más dos más
cuatro más ocho es decir la suma de las
potencias de 3 está suma que tengo aquí
está multiplicando a su vez a la suma de
las potencias de 2 y si nosotros
distribuimos esto que tengo aquí
llegaríamos a esa presión que tengo
justo aquí arriba por lo tanto ahorita
que sacamos nuestro factor común todo va
bien y ojo vuelvo a decirlo ahorita
solamente lo estamos fijando en los
divisores de 27.000 que tienen que ver
con las potencias del 2 y del 3 es decir
estamos variando a x james gaceta lo
estamos dejando igual a 0 y ya con esto
obtenemos esta suma que tenemos aquí
ahora bien hasta aquí va todo genial
pero en el vídeo pasado además
adelantamos un poco más porque dijimos
esta suma que tenemos aquí representa a
cuando nosotros tomamos el 5 elevado a
la 0 es decir 5 elevado a la primera
potencia que es la suma de todo esto que
acabo de calcular ahora
si yo quisiera tomarme la suma de todo
esto mismo pero con 5 elevado a la
primera potencia pues tendrá que
multiplicar esta misma suma por 5 y si
yo quería hacer lo mismo para el 5
elevado a la segunda potencia pues
entonces tendré que tomarme esta suma y
multiplicarlo por 5 elevado al cuadrado
y se asigna que se a tomarme todos esos
unos datos pero por 5 elevado al cubo
pues tendrá que tomarme todo esto y
multiplicarlo por 5 elevado al cubo por
lo tanto vamos a escribirlo para hacer
las cosas mucho más simples voy a decir
que todo esto esa entonces para sacar la
suma total tendría que multiplicar por
15 elevado la potencia cero y esto
sumarle a que multiplica a 5 elevado la
primera potencia y después a esto
sumarle a que multiplica 5 elevado a la
segunda potencia que es 25 y para al
finalizar a todo esto es marley a que
multiplica a 5 elevado a la tercera
potencia es decir aaa por 125 y ésta va
a ser la suma total de todos los
factores de 27.000 y bueno si de aquí
factor izamos a me queda que a
multiplicar tanto a uno como a 5,25 125
y eso tiene toda la lógica del mundo
y si ahora en lugar de poner a am pongo
la expresión que tenemos aquí arriba que
me va a quedar que esto es lo mismo que
13 + 9 + 27 13 + 9 27 no es el mismo
color de verde pero bueno el sentido lo
tienen y esto lo vamos a multiplicar por
12 4 + 8 que esto tenía que ver con las
potencias de 2 y después a esto lo vamos
a multiplicar por 15 más 25 y 125 y ésta
va a ser mi suma total de todos los
factores de 27.000 es decir me voy a
tomar la suma de todas las potencias de
3 después voy a tomar toda la suma de
todas las potencias de 2 después voy a
tomar toda la suma de todas las
potencias de 5 y las voy a multiplicar y
esto lo podemos ver en un caso mucho más
general si nosotros tenemos cualquier
número y hacemos su descomposición en
primos entonces para saber la suma de
todos los factores lo que hay que hacer
es primero tomarme la suma de todas las
potencias del primer primo después la
suma de todas las potencias del segundo
primo y así sucesivamente
y después multiplicar todos estos
resultados en este caso nuestros primos
serán 2
3 y 5 y las potencias varían entre 0 y 3
pero no pueden ser forzosamente lo mismo
sin embargo ya está ya tenemos una nueva
fórmula y vamos a ver cuántos estos 13
más 9 +27 dijimos en el vídeo pasado que
da 40 aquí tengo 2 + 8 son 10 más 4 + 1
son 15 perfecto y por último tengo 25
más 125 150 156 es decir la suma de
todos mis divisores de 27.000 es 40 por
15 por 156 y es más ya que tenemos esto
de una vez vamos a calcular lo 40 por 15
es lo mismo que 20 por 30 que son 600 de
estos dos salen 600 así que dejaron
ponerlo aquí de estos dos van 600 y
después hay que multiplicarlo por 156
cuánto es 600 por 156 pues voy a
multiplicar 156 por 6 y después de
agregó 20 6 por 6 36 llevamos 36 por 5
33 son 33 y llevamos 3 otra vez 6 por
unas 63 son 9 y si después agregamos dos
ceros porque teníamos 600
aquí hay que agregar dos ceros y
llegamos al mismo resultado que la vez
pasada 93.600 aunque tal vez no hice la
demostración con la mayor exactitud lo
que quiero que veas es que la idea en
tuitiva ya la tenemos si tenemos
cualquier número entonces ya podemos
encontrar de una manera mucho más rápida
la suma de todos sus factores así que
para que esto quede mucho más claro y
para entender todo mucho mejor vamos a
hacer un ejemplo para finalizar este
vídeo quiero tomar la suma de todos los
factores de 300 así que lo primero que
hay que hacer es descomponer a 300 en
factores primos y 300 es el mismo que 3
por 100 si es lo mismo que des por 10 y
10 es lo mismo que 2 por 5 y 2 por 5 del
otro 10 entonces 3 y entonces lo mismo
que 3 por 2 al cuadrado por 5 al
cuadrado
esta es la descomposición en primos de
300 ahora bien ya que la tenemos para
sacar la suma de todos los factores de
este número de 300 lo que hay que hacer
es tomarme la suma de todas las posibles
potencias de 3 que es 13 pues 3 el acero
es uno más 3 el a 1 que es 3 y no hay
más ya no en las potencias de 3 porque
hasta ahí
ya estoy multiplicarlo por la suma de
todas las potencias que tenemos del 2 es
decir 1 + 2 más 2 al cuadrado que es 4 y
ya no hay más y después a esto
multiplicarlo por la suma de todas las
potencias de 5 es decir 15 más 5 al
cuadrado que es 25 y ya no se pueden las
potencias porque hasta aquí llega la
potencia del 5 la potencia más grande
del 5 es 2 y por lo tanto tenemos que
parar el 5 al cuadrado y bueno cuántos
estos tres más unos 4 124 es 7 y después
15 25 es 31 7 por 4 28 por 31 cuando es
28 por 31 y me quedan 28 por unos 28
ponemos un cero aquí tres por 824 y
llevamos 23 por 26 más 2 son ocho y
ahora vamos a sumar si pongo lo hecho
aquí me queda 86 8 es decir la suma de
todos los factores de 300 es 868 espero
lo hayas encontrado bastante útil